guten Abend liebe Zuschauer 22 Uhr 16
Uhr an diesem Donnerstagabend gut dass
sie wieder mit dabei sind auf den Wumms
im Juno folgte der doppelwumms im Herbst
nach dem Schock musste die
Bundesregierung für Bürger und
Unternehmen etwas tun Preis Bremsen
Hilfen Beihilfen noch immer ist nicht
alles umgesetzt aber eines steht
offenbar fest Inflation und hohe
Energiepreise sind gekommen um zu
bleiben kann man die einfach weg
subventionieren was tun damit die
Deutschen nicht ärmer werden und die
Industrie nicht auswandert wir müssen
reden mit diesen Gästen
Bundesfinanzminister Christian Lindner
Oppositionsführer Friedrich Merz
der Ökonom Jens südekum
und die Verbraucherschützerin Annabell
Oehlmann
sie sind zu Gast bei Maybrit Illner
Gäste dieser Sendung ausgesprochen
herzlich los geht's die Energiepreise
sind gefallen das haben sie bestimmt
auch mitbekommen die Sorgen bleiben
der Ukraine Krieg hat Deutschlands
langjähriges Geschäftsmodell zerstört
[Musik]
billige Energie aus Russland plötzlich
explodierten die Preise bei Öl Gas und
Strom ich dachte klar Schreibfehler oder
eine verarsche oder sowas das kann ja
kann ja kein Mensch bezeugen jeden Monat
1.000 €46 bleibt ja nichts war übrig die
Bundesregierung unter Druck wir befinden
uns in einem energiekrieg um Wohlstand
und Freiheit
entlastungspakete in Höhe von 100
Milliarden Euro reichten im Sommer nicht
mehr aus um die Lage zu beruhigen die
Bundesregierung legte nochmal drauf
weitere 200 Milliarden man kann sagen
dass es hier ein Doppelpunkt
doch Studenten warten noch immer auf die
versprochene Entlastung auch Verbraucher
die mit Öl oder Pellets heizen die
Energieversorger haben nicht lange
gefackelt und die Abschläge erhöht viele
Verbraucher zahlen jetzt das doppelte
oder dreifache oder mehr
die Märkte haben sich beruhigt sinken
jetzt die Preise ja klar erst wird der
Abschlag vervierfacht dann auf das
Doppelte reduziert Preis gesenkt
ölmann ist bei uns Chefin der
Verbraucherzentrale in Bremen Frau immer
die Menschen müssen jetzt schon diese
Abschläge zahlen weil sie sie monatlich
zahlen und die sind ordentlich wie groß
ist die Angst dass die man eben nicht
gut über das Jahr kommt ja die Angst und
Sorge ist bei vielen VerbraucherInnen
einfach noch wirklich immer groß sie
können auch zum Teil noch gar nicht
abschätzen was bedeutet das jetzt die
gaspreisbremse die strompreisbremse was
bedeutet die Inflation wie gehen wir
damit um viele haben auch das Gefühl es
war bisher schon knapp und jetzt kommt
noch was oben drauf das bringt mich zum
Schwanken und das wichtigste was ich
dann immer nur empfehlen kann ist
wirklich nicht Kopf in den Sand sondern
lieber Taten walten lassen also
Kassensturz Haushaltsbuch gucken und
Hilfe holen im Zweifel was ist auf den
Konten jetzt an Unterstützung schon
angekommen und was eben gar nicht ganz
unterschiedlich je nachdem ob ich zum
Beispiel Mieter bin oder nicht habe ich
den Dezember Abschlag bekommen andere
bekommen ihn erst mit den
Nebenkostenabrechnung im laufenden Jahr
23 und wir wissen auch alle 24
wird auch noch mal ein hartes Jahr also
23 sowieso aber es wird ja noch
langfristig Auswirkungen haben und das
ist das wovor die meisten Menschen
einfach große Sorge haben weil es
niemanden gibt der eine präzise Antwort
geben kann ob das die ob das dicke Ende
noch kommt das auch also einerseits wie
ist die Entwicklung aber viele kämpfen
auch mit dem Verständnis was bedeutet
das jetzt ganz konkret was bedeutet das
wie setzt sich der Preis zusammen wie
soll ich meine Abrechnung verstehen was
wird passieren wenn die strompreisbremse
kommt an wen soll ich mich wenden habe
ich jetzt Anspruch auf Bürgergeld dann
habe ich meinen Antrag gestellt dann
gibt es vielleicht noch ein paar
Rückfragen aber nicht sofort das Geld
und manche sind jetzt wirklich schon so
weit dass sie in den Dispo gehen müssen
wegen wegen der Abschläge um die
laufenden Kosten zu tragen und da kann
ich immer nur sagen dass es natürlich
einer der größten Gefahren weil der
Disco ist für so etwas das wirklich
schlechteste Mittel der ist ja immer nur
zu kurzfristigen Überbrückung geeignet
aber hier brauchen wir andere Wege und
andere Möglichkeiten und es gibt viele
Ansätze also es gibt viele
härtefallfonds und andere auffangen
Möglichkeiten Wohngeld Bürgergeld aber
die Menschen das wissen oft nicht um
ihre Option und was tun sie dann am
Telefon Frau Oehlmann dann sagen Sie
also 80 Prozent das kommt alles im März
und dann haben sie hoffentlich bis dahin
ein bisschen Energie gespart das tut
natürlich jeder aber keiner Weise ob es
reichen wird was man gespart hat also
das Wichtigste ist dass wir tatsächlich
in online-formaten informieren sonst
würden wir den Ansturm gar nicht
schaffen also dass wir wirklich online
Torx machen kurzes Sessions wo wir die
Sachen erklären gute FAQ Listen
natürlich auf unseren Fragen und
Antworten ne also das klassische was
aber auch die Stadtwerke bei uns genauso
macht in Bremen und das auch mit uns
abstimmt damit wir möglichst aus einer
Stimme sprechen und einfach gut erklären
die Menschen sind im Moment extrem
verunsichert und bei jeder Änderung
rennen Sie uns sofort die Bude ein was
ja auch gut ist ne also ich will ja gar
nichts gegen sagen sie sollen kommen und
sollen Fragen
Parteivorsitzender und Finanzminister
Christian Lindner ist bei uns Herr
Lindner haben sie diese
Abschlagsrechnung schon bekommen also
ihre nein ich bin Mieter und deshalb
kommt das bei mir auch zum späteren
Zeitpunkt ich finde richtig was will man
sagt das höre ich auch von vielen
Energieversorgern deren Hotlines werden
sehr stark in Anspruch genommen weil es
eine große Verunsicherung gibt ist ja
auch verstellbar wir sind in sehr
bewegten Zeiten die Preise schwanken und
auch noch nicht all das was die Politik
beschlossen hat kommt bei den Menschen
an was man aber sagen kann ist dass wir
in wirtschaftlichen Abwehrschirm
gespannt haben der mit der Strom und der
gaspreisbremse die für die Menschen und
Betriebe ruinösen preisspitzenkappen
wird es gibt auch härtefallfonds sie
haben darauf hingewiesen Frau ölmann und
wir haben darüber hinaus ja auch für die
breite Mitte der Gesellschaft
zusätzliche Maßnahmen auf den Weg
gebracht ich nehme mal ein Beispiel eine
Familie mit zwei Kindern vierköpfig also
die 55.000 Euro im Jahr verdient die
zahlt 800 € weniger Steuern in diesem
Jahr also wir haben in der ganzen Breite
für die ganz unterschiedlichen
Sachverhalte Hilfen und Entlastungen
angeboten aber auch wirken müssen ich
Studenten müssen Sie bitte noch sagen
warum ist das so schwierig dass die
Studenten diese 200 Euro kriegen und
natürlich Öl und Pellets also da gibt es
ja sogar schon große bitten von
Ministerpräsidenten Herr wüst war der
letzte der sagte Olaf Scholz hat sein
Wort gegeben dass die Menschen die mit
Öl und Pellets heißen auch die Firmen
genauso eine Entlastung kriegen das ist
etwas anders war ja bei der
entsprechenden
Ministerpräsidentenkonferenz dabei es
wurde Geld seitens des Bundes
bereitgestellt um zusammen mit den
Ländern solche härtefallfonds
aufzusetzen die Verwaltung der
härtefallfonds macht aber nicht der Bund
das machen die Länder und auf der
anderen Seite bei den Studierenden ist
ja auch Mittel des Bundes nur gibt es
eben keine direkte Beziehung zwischen
den Studierenden und den
bundeshaushaltisierten ja
Digitalisierung Verwaltung das
interessiert die Leute im Zweifel nicht
deshalb die klare Zusage ist es wird mit
Hochdruck daran gearbeitet dass nur noch
technische Probleme zu lösen finanziell
und politisch besteht ich glaube
Einvernehmen auch über die Parteigrenzen
hinweg ist nur nicht immer administrativ
alles von jetzt auf gleich so schnell
wie man sich das wünscht zu lösen
besprechen wir weiter Friedrich Merz ist
bei uns
Oppositionsführer und Vorsitzender der
CDU Herr Merz der heiße Herbst ist
ausgeblieben die große Katastrophe ist
ausgeblieben aber der Zustand ist auch
nicht
besonders schön den man jetzt nein der
ist nicht schön und wir leben ja nun und
das hat Christian Lindner völlig zu
Recht so gesagt wir leben in
außergewöhnlichen Zeiten dass wir dass
wir jetzt vor knapp einem Jahr erlebt
haben der Angriffskrieg auf die Ukraine
den wir in dieser Form nicht vorhersehen
konnten hat vieles verändert und das was
Frau Willmann hier gerade beschrieben
hat mit den Verbraucherzentralen ist das
was wir als Wahlkreisabgeordnete jeden
Tag hören und ich will das mal bei
dieser Gelegenheit sagen gut dass wir
dann auch die Verbraucherzentralen haben
sie können das wirklich professionell
auch informieren und weitergeben
wir verweisen häufig dann auch auf sie
und sagen dann auch denen die bei uns
anrufen dass die Verbraucherzentrale nie
eine wirklich gute Arbeit leisten und
gute Informationen geben aber das
Problem ist natürlich trotzdem dass wir
mit vielen Dingen sehr sehr spät sind
dass zum Beispiel die Studenten und
Studentinnen bis heute darauf warten
dass das Geld ausgezahlt wird die
Rentnerinnen und Rentner sind vergessen
worden von der Regierung das haben wir
dann gesagt und das ist dann nachgeholt
worden 300 € energiegeld hat es im
letzten Jahr für alle gegeben war das
eigentlich richtig ich habe den
Vorschlag gemacht lieber 1000 € für das
untere Drittel als 300 € für alle also
da sind schon ein paar handwerkliche und
strukturelle Fehler gemacht worden die
man hätte vermeiden können aber ich
gestehe der Regierung zu es ist eine
Ausnahme Situation dafür gibt es keinen
Regiebuch das hat von uns niemand auf
dem Zettel gehabt dass wir so etwas mal
machen müssen nehme für uns in Anspruch
gaspreisbremse Strompreis Bremse haben
wir schon immer August das letzten
Jahres vorgeschlagen zu einem Zeitpunkt
wo die Regierung noch über die gasumlage
gestritten
wird das hier in südekum bei uns ist
Ökonom von der Uni Düsseldorf Herr
südekum diese diese Umstand dass das
alles so in Not und in einem irrsinnigen
hat dann zum Jahresende hingestellt
wurde damit man den Menschen eben in
diese Gas und strompreisbremsen anbieten
konnte ist das in ihren Augen
begründet gewesen sie haben auch zu
denen gehört die im Sommer gefordert
haben da muss es jetzt Unterstützung
geben und zwar zügig woran lag das warum
kommen die nicht nein insgesamt sind die
drei entlastungspakete plus die Strom
und gasbremse schon ein wuchtiges und
gutes Programm aber optimal sind sie
nicht das hätte besser laufen können die
Strom und gaspreisbremse die
grundsätzlichen Vorschläge wie man das
hätte machen können die lagen alle im
Prinzip im März April auf dem Tisch und
über den Sommer hieß es dann aber das
sind alles Schöne ich habe selber auch
einen gemacht also sogenannter
Energiesparmodus der hätte dann so den
Bund etwa zwischen 6 und 10 Milliarden
Euro gekostet also im Vergleich zum
doppelwumms ein äußerst Bescheid Antrag
und im Sommer war die klare Ansage
vorgestellt auch der Bundesregierung ja
das sind tolle Vorschläge aber zu teuer
das geht leider nicht eine Haushalt ist
auf Kante genäht und die oberste
Priorität ist die schnelle
wiedereinhaltung der Schuldenbremse und
das obwohl wir Lindner gesagt in einem
Wirtschaftskrieg uns befinden am
energiekrieg und dann musste ja eine
Kehrtwende hingelegt werden mit dem
Doppelpunkt das war der 29 September
dann war plötzlich Geld da keiner hat
damit gerechnet und dann mussten über
Nacht diese preisbremsen schnell
konzipiert werden in einem in einer
Windeseile also die gaskommission die
die Vorschläge gemacht hat die hatte
ungefähr ein Wochenende Zeit und das
Ganze zu machen aber es war definitiv
und Wasser rausgekommen ist ist schon
gut das will ich jetzt nicht bestreiten
aber man hätte noch mehr machen können
zum Beispiel eben diese soziale
Staffelung also auch wir wie wir hier
sitzen profitieren von der
strompreisbremse wo man eigentlich sagen
müsste eigentlich nicht gebraucht
die strompreisbremse wird finanziert
über eine Abschöpfung bei den
Energiekonzernen und ich finde ja zu
einem sehr großen Teil und ich finde
wenn es eine Verteilung innerhalb des
Systems gibt dann sollen davon auch alle
profitieren bei der gaspreisbremse ist
es anders da werden auch Steuermittel
eingesetzt deshalb wird die ja auch
besteuert werden das heißt da wird die
individuelle Leistungsfähigkeit der
Bürgerinnen und Bürger berücksichtigt
diejenigen die in höheres Einkommen
haben werden weniger profitieren
dass sie sehr lange an der
Schuldenbremse festgehalten haben Herr
Lindner würden sie das heute wir sind im
nächsten Jahr manchmal wird man ja
klüger würden sie das heute früher
gemacht haben absolut halte ich auch
weiter an der Schuldenbremse fest man
muss ja noch mal in der Situation mit
ihrem Kabinett und den Kollegen
entschieden haben das zu einem früheren
Zeitpunkt des letzten Jahres hätte etwas
geschehen ab dem Zeitpunkt als es den
Sabotage Anschlag auf die
Pipeline in nordstream 1 Pipeline
gegeben hat haben wir ja die politischen
Prioritäten verändert diejenigen die vor
dieser
Eskalation in energiepolitischer
Hinsicht Forderungen gemacht haben haben
ja generell immer die Schuldenbremse
abgelehnt ich kann nur sagen wir haben
jetzt das Notwendige getan wir gehen
aber mit dem öffentlichen Geld
sorgfältig um wir zahlen dafür hohe
Zinsen jede Milliarde die wir jetzt
ausgeben an Hilfe ist nur geborgtes Geld
das wird von den Menschen gezählt werden
müssen dafür zahlen wir inzwischen hohe
Zinsen und deshalb ich lass mich gern
dafür kritisieren aber ich halte daran
fest wir brauchen nachhaltig tragfähige
öffentliche Finanzen weshalb wenn ich
das noch sagen darf ist ja auch nur bis
zu 200 Milliarden sind jede Milliarde
die wir nicht brauchen ist im Interesse
der Bürgerinnen und Bürger aber erstmal
wurde aus der Not ja Geld quasi aus dem
Flugzeug verteilt in Deutschland weil
man erst mal sehr schnell merkt
sie zurückweisen das Geld aus dem
Flugzeug verteilt worden ist wir haben
eine Strom und eine gaspreisbremse von
einer Expertenkommission konzipieren
lassen ja aber ich will auf einen
wichtigen Punkt hinaus weil sie sagen
mit dem Hubschrauber abgeworfen wir
erhalten die Anreize für sparsamen
Umgang mit Energie da werden wir sogar
von internationalen Organisationen wie
dem Internationalen Währungsfond gelobt
und wenn ich das auch mal sagen darf ich
bin absolut selbstkritisch und wir sind
in einer Ausnahmesituation wo nicht jede
Entscheidung gelingt und mit
Unsicherheiten arbeitet wo auch man sich
korrigieren muss aber im Ergebnis ist
unser Land gut durch das Jahr 2022
gekommen und die internationalen Medien
erkennen das auch an anders als unsere
innenpolitische Debatte wir sind aber
bei den Bürgern und die Bürger zahlen
gerade Entschuldigung die Bürger zahlen
gerade hohe Abschläge und sind voller
Sorge Herr Süde kommen das und was noch
auf sie zukommen wird weil sie
Entspannung haben wie am Ende die
Rechnung aussieht warum ist das so und
für wen ist das besonders schlimm für
die Mieter nämlich für die Mieter ist
die Situation glaube ich am
schwierigsten denn wenn man mal auf die
aktuelle Preisentwicklung schaut was
kostet heute ein Neuvertrag für Strom
und für Gas dann ich habe heute morgen
geschaut Gas 12 Cent Strom 38 Cent das
heißt ein Haushalt der sich heute
eindecken kann mit einem neuen Vertrag
der würde so gesehen gar nicht mehr
profitieren von der Strom in der Gas
weil die werden die Preise drunter
liegen und das ist natürlich die Folge
der Preis Rückgänge die wir an dem
Börsen in den letzten Wochen und Monaten
gesehen haben jetzt ist das Problem
viele machen keine direkten Verträge mit
den Versorgern sondern ihr Vermieter
muss das tun und sie müssen quasi dann
auf die Abschlagszahlung warten und das
ist das große Problem deswegen rate ich
oder das kann auch irgendwann besser
sagen ja das gerade Mieterinnen und
Mieter sehr genau schauen sollten was
machen jetzt gerade die Vermieter
schauen nicht aktiv nach dem besten
Vertrag ja und auch was machen die
Versorger geben die auch wirklich fair
die gesunkene Beschaffungskosten auch an
die Menschen weiter zwei wichtige Fragen
gehen gleich an die Politik aber wir
wollen unbedingt von Frau Oehlmann
wissen da sind also an beiden
sogenannten Börsen an der Strom und an
der gasbörse die Preise eklatant
gesunken streckenweise auch auf
Vorkriegsniveau und die Bürger wissen
immer noch nicht was davon bei Ihnen
ankommt oder nicht ankommt das kommt ja
auch immer darauf an was für ein Vertrag
ich habe viele haben die Preiserhöhungen
bekommen haben da nicht das
Sonderkündigungsrecht in Anspruch
genommen und sind jetzt in einem Vertrag
der viel viel teurer ist also auch als
Hauseigentümer oder als Mieter der einen
eigenen Vertrag hat kann man es versaut
haben an der Stelle und sich jetzt
ärgern bin ich aber in der
Grundversorgung habe ich z.B die
Möglichkeit innerhalb von 14 Tagen auch
rauszugehen aber wir sind alle noch
unsicher der Markt kommt oder kommt
gerade in Bewegung aber wie lange das
anhält wir erinnern uns alle an gas.de
Grünwelt ich weiß nicht das war 21 Ende
21 die man eben alle Leute vor die Tür
gesetzt haben und ihre Lieferungen
eingestellt haben weil sie woanders
bessere Preise bekommen haben ich werde
auch immer sehr vorsichtig und viele
dieser Vertragsangebote haben eine
24-monatige Laufzeit ich würde in diesem
Zeiten genau gar nichts abschließen was
24 Monate dauert wenn ich ehrlich bin
also lieber kritisch weiter beobachten
und im Zweifel ein bisschen später
wechseln weil sonst zahlt man richtig
drauf so das ist noch mal ein wichtiger
Hinweis auch für unsere Zuschauer weil
diese ihr müsst jetzt unbedingt die
Verträge wechseln Empfehlungen sind ja
zu Hauf unterwegs übrigens auch
betrügerisch und übers Handy wir haben
sehr vielen Bürgern dieses Landes da
raten Sie das auf gar keinen Fall zu tun
weil man nicht wissen kann ob diese
billige Anbieter gegebenenfalls ein
Billigheimer ist ganz genau und im
Zweifel immer es gibt eine kostenlose
Energieberatung in der
Verbraucherzentrale da hat man eine
Hotline da kann man Video mäßig beraten
werden da kann man persönlich beraten
werden kommen Sie vorbei wir sind
bundesweit vertreten bevor man mit einem
schlechten Gefühl irgendwas
unterschreibt und es dann Monate bereut
und gerade in diesen Zeiten kann man
sich nicht leisten wir kommen zu einer
politischen und juristischen Frage Herr
Merz sie haben auch darauf hingewiesen
dass eigentlich die Bundesnetzagentur
das Kartellamt überprüfen müsste ob die
Versorger über die wir gerade sprechen
diese sinkenden Preise weitergeben wir
haben schon mal verstanden dass die in
unterschiedlichen Jahresabschnitten
eingekauft werden manche für drei Jahre
man sieht nur Kontingente wer
kontrolliert ist die klare Frage wer
kontrolliert und schafft das das
Kartellamt überhaupt zu kontrollieren
dass Versorger nicht so lange warten bis
es nicht mehr geht um dann irgendwann
diese Preise weiterzugeben oder ist auch
gar nicht zu tun na gut das
Bundeskartellamt ist eine
missbrauchsbehörde und keine
preisaufsichtsbehörde normalerweise
regelt bei uns Angebote und Nachfrage
den Preis und das war ja ein
wesentlicher Teil auch der
Auseinandersetzung die wir mit der
Koalition hatten Strom war ja auch in
Deutschland schon vor dem Krieg teuer
wir schon vor dem Krieg mit die höchsten
Energiepreise in ganz Europa von der
Welt mal ganz zu schweigen und deswegen
war unser Punkt immer wir müssen das
Angebot ausweiten und zwar nicht so
gerade eben wie viel wir brauchen hart
auf Kante genäht sondern wirklich
substanziell ein Überangebot schaffen
und wenn wir das tun ja nur wir müssen
vielleicht doch den Zuschauern mal
erklären was wir hier machen ist
sozusagen am Ende der Kette zu
kontrollieren ist da irgendwas machbar
was man korrigieren kann am Anfang steht
das Angebot und wenn wir in Deutschland
ein hohes Angebot ich würde sogar sagen
ein Überangebot an
Stromerzeugungskapazitäten hätten dann
hätten wir viele preisdiskussionen
überhaupt nicht zu führen weil wir dann
eben im Markt ein hohes Angebot bei
einer Nachfrage hätten die auch den
Preis stark beeinflussen kann dann
kommen wir noch mal dazu ich frage
keinen südekum die Preise unterscheiden
sich selbst bei Stadtwerken massiv also
selbst bei regionalen Anbietern und eben
nicht den Grundversorgern noch mal die
Frage wie kann und wer wird am Ende
sagen und kontrollieren ob das was die
Versorger jetzt dem Bürger zur Zahlung
anweisen ob das ein fairer und gerechter
Preis ist
aprikosition hat ja das kartellat mit
einem ziemlich scharfen Schwerter
ausgestattet nämlich einer Umkehr der
Beweislast das heißt natürlich ist es
jetzt gerade das Problem das Versorger
jetzt mal so testhalber ihre Preise
erhöhen können und dann eben darauf
spekulieren dass die Kundschaft wohl
nicht abspringen wird weil am Ende ja
sowieso so kommt der landläufig an der
Stadt bezahlt alles was über die 12 Cent
hinausgeht ne also die genau
Konstruktion ist etwas komplizierter
aber im Prinzip hat man ja die
Sicherheit für 80% des Feuers verbraucht
für dieses Kontingent zahlt man eben nur
diese garantierten 12 Cent und dann
können die Versager natürlich versuchen
ein bisschen aufzugeben und einige tun
es auch guten Grund weil ja in die
Beschaffungskosten tatsächlich gestiegen
sind
da wäre das dann so gesehen
gerechtfertigt aber das Kartellamt kann
ja jetzt eben schauen sind jetzt die
Preiserhöhung die der stattfinden
tatsächlich gerechtfertigt durch
gestiegene Beschaffungskosten oder
versucht da jetzt ein Versorger
abzukassieren und das wäre extrem
schwierig wenn das kartellern demjenigen
das dann nachweisen müsste aber jetzt
ist es so dass das Kartellamt eben den
muss das eher das begründen muss ob eben
tatsächlich diese Preiserhöhung
substanziell gerechtfertigt war und Frau
Ullmann fragt sich sicherlich auch ob
Sie zukünftig ihren Kunden dann eben
private klagen empfehlen muss oder nicht
ja das wird das sein was sich der
Verbraucher selber natürlich nicht
leisten kann an der Stelle das heißt das
wird auch wahrscheinlich
musterfeststellungsklagen die ersten
laufen auch schon ähm hinauslaufen weil
es gibt schon einzelne Anbieter die sehr
unangenehm und häufig auffallen mit
Abschlägen die unverhältnismäßig hoch
sind oder auch mit Preiserhöhungen die
gefühlt per Werbebotschaft mitgeteilt
werden also kein rechts mit und der
Vertrag wurde aber untergejubelt da gibt
es schon die ersten Prozesse aber auch
das können die Verbraucherzentrale
natürlich nicht leisten wenn es in der
Menge und Größe betrieben wird sehr
viele Stadtwerke und Energieversorger
kalkulieren ja aber auch sehr genau und
schauen ganz genau was sie machen und
gucken dass sie wirklich möglichst wenig
weitergeben wir haben in Bremen das
große Glück und das mussten wir den
Menschen auch erstmal beibringen das
Strom und gaspreisbremse kaum in
Anspruch genommen werden und das ist was
Gutes ist bei der eigentliche Vertrag
unter diesen Preisgrenzen sitzt ne also
das ist eigentlich ein gutes Zeichen das
muss man auch sagen es sind ja nicht
alle Bürgerinnen und Bürger betroffen
manche haben noch ältere Verträge und
Süde kommen ohne jetzt in die Details
gehen zu wollen hat ja auch schon zum
Ausdruck gebracht dass der Gesetzgeber
hier Vorkehrungen getroffen hat gegen
Missbrauch so dass möglichst wenige
Verbraucherinnen und Verbraucher selbst
den Rechtsweg bestreiten müssen das ist
mitgedacht und vielleicht muss man auch
den marktprozessen den
Anpassungsprozessen noch ein paar Wochen
Zeit geben es ist ja sehr beweglicher
Markt und die Bremsen genau die Bremsen
kommen ja erst jetzt im nächsten Monat
die Unsicherheit war zu thematisieren
die Bürger wissen erstmal nicht was sie
zahlen sie haben das Gefühl es wird
nicht billiger aber vermutlich wird es
wirklich billiger für den Finanzminister
Herr Lindner sie haben gerechnet dass 83
Milliarden 86 Milliarden für diese
beiden preisbremsen draufgehen und nun
stellen wir fest da gibt es interessante
Recherchen von Verivox und dem Spiegel
dass sie wahrscheinlich nur einstellig
mit beiden Bremsen durch dieses Jahr
kommen reißen sie da innerlich schon mal
die Arme hoch und sind das berechtigte
es ist ja nicht mein Geld es ist das
Geld der Bürgerinnen und Bürger es sind
ja auch die Schulden der Bürgerinnen und
Bürger also insofern nicht ich reise die
Arme hoch sondern wir alle gemeinsam
hoffen dass wir gut durch diese Krise
kommen weil Schulden machen uns alle
gesellschaftlich ärmer was die zahlen
und Spekulationen angeht sollten wir
aber abwarten wir haben jetzt den Winter
22 23 wir haben auch noch einen Winter
23 24 wo wir nicht wissen wie wir die
Preisentwicklung sein wir haben unseren
Schutzschirm wir wissen nicht wie wir
Ihnen Anspruch nehmen und in der und in
der kleinen ja ist Boarding von jemand
anderem nicht mein Begriff und im
übrigen ist ihre Liste nicht leider
nicht ganz vollständig die harte Fälle
zahlen wir auch daraus da zahlen wir
auch Hilfen beispielsweise für
Krankenhäuser mit enthalten ist die
Stabilisierung von Unternehmen die
Beschaffungskosten haben weil sie nicht
mehr russisches Gas haben also insofern
abwarten wenn wir die 200 Milliarden
nicht voll in Anspruch nehmen können ist
das eine gute Nachricht dann machen wir
nämlich weniger Schulden kann jetzt
schon sagen weil ich ahne ich kenn ja
inzwischen die Debatten in Deutschland
es wird eine Diskussion geben wenn die
Milliarden Euro nicht ausgeschöpft
werden ja können wir diese
kreditermächtigung nicht für andere gute
Zwecke einsetzen ich höre die Debatte
schon und da kann ich sagen nein aus
verfassungsrechtlichen aus
verfassungsrechtlichen Gründen als
unberechtigt wäre die Forderung aber
natürlich nicht es kommt natürlich immer
darauf an wofür es da eingesetzt wurde
aber für eine längerfristige
Versicherung die dann dafür Sorge trägt
dass eine solche Krise jetzt nicht schon
ganz schnell wiederkommt würde ich das
durchaus einsetzen wollen dieses Geld
also zum Beispiel durch einen noch mal
beschleunigten Ausbau der Erneuerbaren
Ausbau der Energieinfrastruktur das
sorgt dann ja eben dafür dass solche
Krisen nicht über nächstes Jahr schon
wieder kommen also die Infrastruktur
auch die ähm bei den erneuerbaren
Energien bauen wir ja auf dafür haben
wir ja Mittel Friedrich März hat ja
völlig recht als er eben gesagt hat wir
müssen die
energieerzeugungskapazitäten in
Deutschland ausdehnen auch übrigens
heimische Energieträger wie Gas und Öl
nutzen ist nur ein bisschen amüsant wenn
er sagt wir also die CDU haben das immer
gesagt weil bis
25 war ja die Verantwortung für die
Energiepolitik bei der Union aber
geschenkt wir schauen nach vorne nur aus
den 200 Milliarden jetzt also wiederum
können wir es nicht tun weil die sind
gesetzlich vom zwecks gebunden und das
Verfassungsgericht sagt wenn man
notlagenkredite aufnimmt wie ich das
jetzt getan habe dann müssen die für
einen Zweck eingesetzt werden man kann
sie nicht auf Dauer nutzen so und Herr
März Opposition hat von einem Sprengsatz
im Bundeshaushalt gesprochen von 100
Milliarden 200 also insgesamt 300
Milliarden die anders definiert wurden
und nun gerade nicht signalisieren dass
man spart wenn da tatsächlich weniger
ausgegeben werden kann würden Sie sagen
dann wäre gut dieses Geld in diese oder
andere Bereiche zu investieren oder
sagen Sie wie gut dass wir dann
insgesamt weniger von diesen Schatten
Haushalten
ich verstehe die Frage einigermaßen es
kommt drauf an ist meine Antwort und
zwar ganz entscheidend
darüber reden wir also wenn wir über 100
Milliarden sogenannte Sondervermögen für
die Bundeswehr sprechen dann wollen wir
dass das zügig ausgegeben wird weil die
Bundeswehr das Geld braucht wenn wir
über 230 Milliarden Euro
Verpflichtungsermächtigungen neue
Schulden im Bundeshaushalt 2022 reden
die wir für diese Krise Bundesregierung
für diese Krise vorhält dann ist es gut
über jede Milliarde die nicht ausgegeben
werden muss allerdings das Geld was die
Bürgerinnen und Bürger was auch die
Firmen brauchen und zwar schon seit
einigen Monaten wäre gut wenn es jetzt
mal zur Verfügung stände und dann sind
wir exakt bei dem Thema das große
Energiekonzerne wenigstens mittendrin
sind eben diesen goldenen Zeiten
Big Oil macht Big Money Europas größter
Öl- und Gaskonzern shell hat seinen
Gewinn im letzten Jahr verdoppelt auf
fast 40 Milliarden Dollar das beste
Ergebnis der Konzerngeschichte Shell ist
nicht allein auch BP und die US-Konzerne
Exon mobil und Chevron vermählten
Rekordgewinne sie profitieren von den
Folgen des Krieges
Rekordgewinne ärgern den US-Präsidenten
outrages nennt das Weiße Haus den Gewinn
von extern empörend
alle sind bemüht das richtige in dieser
Krise zu tun nur die Ölindustrie nicht
die EU will die übergewinne abschöpfen
damit die Mitgliedsstaaten ihre Bürger
entlasten können
exonmobil könnte das 2 Milliarden Dollar
kosten kommt nicht in frage sagt der
Konzern und klagt gegen die EU
und damit sind wir schon wieder bei
Christian Lindner
exson ist das eine unsere
Stromproduzenten E.on und RWE sind das
andere große deutsche Krisengewinner
kann man sagen es gibt eine
eu-verwaltungsrichtlinie die ermöglicht
auch der Bundesregierung Ihnen
ermöglicht sogenannte übergewinne
einzuziehen mit wie viel Milliarden
rechnen sie da heilender wir haben zwei
Instrumente das erste Instrument bezieht
sich auf die
Stromkonzerne die Sie gerade genannt
haben bei den Stromkonzernen die wir
eben schon mal kurz angesprochen haben
ergreifen wir in die Preisbildung am
Strommarkt ein und schöpfen
zufallsgewinner ab was sind Zufalls
Gewinne die Preise errichten sich nach
dem letzten Kraftwerk das zugeschaltet
wird das ist oft ein teures Gaskraftwerk
und auch die günstigeren Kraftwerke auch
die Windkraftwerke zum Beispiel werden
so bezahlt als hätten sie Gas eingekauft
ein Zufall genauso heißt das ist ein
Zufalls gewinnen und den schöpfen wir ab
und legen ihn quasi um auf die
stromverbraucherinnen und
Stromverbraucher wie viel wird das
bringen denken Sie das weiß man nicht
wir wissen ja nicht wie die Preise sich
entwickeln aber es gibt eine Abschöpfung
und daneben hat die Europäische Union
das kam in ihrem Beitrag ja gerade zum
Ausdruck ein
eu-solidarbeitrag beschlossen dieser
eu-solidarbeitrag wird entrichtet zum
Beispiel von den Unternehmen in der
Ölbranche aber da haben wir in
Deutschland wenig Exon ist kein
deutsches Unternehmen also insofern das
sind in Deutschland sehr wenige
Betroffene deshalb ist da nicht mit sehr
viel Geld zu rechnen
wie sieht Ihre Rechnung aus die noch
nicht also eine prophetische Rechnung
aber was denken sie kann da an Geldern
in das steuersäcke Marschieren damit es
eben einigermaßen fair zu geben also von
Seiten der Ölunternehmen wird EU weit
das war mit 25 Milliarden aufkommen
gerechnet und für Deutschland so zwei
bis drei Milliarden sie dabei rumkommen
und das wird dann auf den einzelnen
Ländern Europas verteilt Entschuldigung
nicht an die einzelnen Länder teilen ein
okay die erste Schätzung von einem
südkum die wir gemacht haben in der
Bundesregierung war genau die Zahl die
er gesagt hat zwei bis drei ehrlich
gesagt ist eine neuere Schätzung eher
bei unter einer Milliarde für
Deutschland aber wir werden es am Ende
sehen ja es ist eingeführtes Gesetz und
werden sie da muss man natürlich sagen
wenn ich die Zahlen jetzt gerade noch
mal sehe welche Gewinde da gemacht
wurden da ist das natürlich ein Tropfen
auf den heißen stark was dort
abgeschöpft wurde von den Ölunternehmen
und die Argumente die dagegen
vorgebracht wurden ja dass dann jetzt
diese übergewinnsteuer jetzt tatsächlich
dazu führt dass diese Unternehmen
weniger investieren und so weiter ich
meine da glaube ich wahrscheinlich nicht
mehr selber dran das ist ein Witz das
heißt also ich glaube ich sie ist ein
bisschen so dass beim Thema
übergewinnsteuer auch die
Bundesregierung durchaus mehr hätte
machen können und auch höhere
Steuersätze oder implementieren können
auf europäischer Ebene da war aber
glaube ich nach meiner Beobachtung
wieder ein bisschen das Problem
dass sie hier Lindner immer so ein
bisschen auch Probleme haben einfach mit
diesem Begriff Steuererhöhungen ja dass
das einfach tun ist vermieden werden
sollte und ich werde sagen an der Stelle
hätte man da anders vorgehen müssen ich
habe keinen Problem mit irgendwas es
muss nur sinnvoll sein und tatsächlich
bin ich dagegen zu definieren was ist
ein Gewinn und was ist ein sogenannter
übergewinn ähm
nein das öffnet dem ganzen Tür und Tor
und der Willkür ist nicht berechenbar
wir haben noch Abgrenzungsprobleme
rechtliche Probleme viele Länder in
Europa die eine sogenannte
übergewinnsteuer eingeführt haben ich
denke etwa an Italien werden ja beklagt
das heißt es ist sehr schwieriges
Instrument ich glaube wir haben in
Deutschland den richtigen Weg gefunden
wir machen beim Strommarkt ein
Instrument und greifen da ein wo die
Gewinne oder bevor die Gewinne überhaupt
in der dem spilanz sind also in die
Preisbildung dort im Notfall und wir
setzen diesen eu-solidarbeitrag um aber
wie gesagt wir haben in Deutschland auch
gar keine öding man muss nur sagen mit
Exon 54 Milliarden Euro Gewinn macht und
das ist eine Gewinnzahlen von 140%
gegenüber dem Vorjahr also mehr als eine
Verdopplung dann hat das nichts mit
unternehmerischer Leistung mit
Innovation oder irgendwas zu tun das ist
lediglich den Krieg und den markenfeld
geschrieben das heißt da jetzt eine
Diskussion zu will was ist dann
übergewinn eine rein theoretische
Diskussion für das ist
in Deutschland eine Diskussion ich führe
jetzt ja nicht die Diskussion mit Ihnen
als amerikanischer Finanzminister wo
Exon sitzt die sitzen hast sondern ich
ich führe mit ihnen eine Diskussion über
die Unternehmen die ihren sitzt z.B in
Essen haben aber die EU hätte statt
eines Steuersatzes von 33% auf die
übergewinde auch 50 oder 60% an visieren
können dann wäre ein bisschen mehr Geld
reingekommen und dann ist wahnsinnig
interessant der März dazu zu hören
würden Sie sagen März es wäre eine
schlichte Frage der Gerechtigkeit dass
Gewinne die wir Sünde krumm sagt mit
Leistung und mit besonderer Performance
neudeutsch nichts zu tun haben
können weil es eben ein Zufall gab der
für solche Einnahmen gesorgt hat
beides ist richtig was was asylikum und
was Christian Lindner sagen es ist
natürlich ist widerspricht dem
Gerechtigkeitsempfinden eines jenes
normal denkenden Menschen was da im
Augenblick passiert trotzdem ist
natürlich richtig dass ein übergewinn zu
definieren im steuerrechtlich Zulässigen
und gerichtsfesten Sinne extrem
schwierig ist da können sie Bilanzen
vergleichen da können sie Gewinne
vergleichen der Vorjahre das wird
hochgradig anfechtbar
schon mal getraut na gut aber wir wollen
mal sehen was dabei rauskommt ist wäre
besser wir würden differenzieren
zwischen Öl und Strom im Ölmarkt ist das
sicherlich gut begründbar und
darstellbar im Strommarkt wird es
schwierig schauen sie mal auf die
kraftbetreiber in Deutschland und auf
die Solarenergiebranche die im Jahr 2020
große Gewinne gemacht haben sonst sind
das übergewinne wie definieren wir die
ja das kann man machen ich sage nur noch
mal ist bessere wäre gewesen ein so
brutales Überangebot an Stromerzeugung
zu schaffen und da kommen wir nicht drum
herum jetzt auch über die Kernenergie zu
sprechen die versorgt immerhin 10
Millionen Haushalt in Deutschland zu
weil er sie mit Strom zu sagen wir
nutzen jede Quelle zur Stromerzeugung um
auf diese Art und Weise die Preise aber
dafür gerade wir haben jetzt gerade
alles an Kohle rechtlich möglich am Netz
und die Kernenergie das muss ich doch
mal sagen wenn Friedrich Merz für mehr
Kapazität bei der Energieerzeugung wird
das ist ja gut aber wir sind jetzt nicht
im Jahr 2016 wo man die Kraftwerke des
Jahres 2023 hätte planen können wir sind
schon in 23 wir planen jetzt die
energiekapazitäten für 2028 muss man
dann doch mal sein aber die diskuss
schon über die kernallergie haben wir
gehabt im letzten Jahr da hat die
Koalition mit einem Machtwort gegen die
FDP anders entschieden als es eigentlich
sinnvoll und vernünftig gewesen
auch dass das jetzt erstmal eine
Entscheidung dieser Bundesregierung ist
und dass wir auf der anderen Seite
tatsächlich Firmen haben die unverhofft
kommt oft zu sehr viel Geld gekommen
sind durch diese Krise Frau Ullmann wenn
es nur ein Symbol wäre wäre es trotzdem
ein wichtiges
ich schwanke genauso moralisch ist das
für mich eine völlig klare Sache
brauchen wir nicht darüber diskutieren
ich persönlich finde aber auch noch wir
hätten einer kleineren Gruppe in der
Bevölkerung viel stärker helfen müssen
und viele andere hätten gar keine Hilfe
gebraucht also das ist immer noch meine
meine Haltung an der Stelle aber
ökonomisch verstehe ich einerseits die
Probleme andererseits fand ich aber auch
sehr interessant wie Sie es gerade
betrachtet haben aber da gebe ich ganz
klar ab da brauche ich nicht machen ist
nicht mein Job meine Lehrerin liefern
Frage das ist juristisch anfechtbar
sonst würde das ja extra nicht machen
die verteilen jetzt 15 Milliarden lieber
unter ihren Aktionären und wollen nicht
die zwei Milliarden ansehen statt zahlen
also kann man das Vergleichen mit der
Rüstungsindustrie jetzt die auch in
Deutschland beispielsweise sehr viel
Geld verdienen wird weil es diesen Krieg
gibt weil Russland die Ukraine
angegriffen hat und weil es jetzt einen
unglaublichen Bedarf gibt Militär Herz
Stellen sind das dann auch
zufallsgewinne und müssten die
beschränkt werden
also ich finde da Vergleich hinkt ein
bisschen weil bei den Ölkonzernen ist es
ja eben so dass plötzlich
Preisbewegungen im Weltmarkt
letztendlich über Nacht die Gewinnmargen
verdoppelt verdreifacht haben jetzt bei
den Rüstungskonzernen ist es eben wir
haben uns entschieden dass wir die
Bundeswehr ganz anders ausstatten müssen
um gerüstet zu sein und natürlich freut
sich rein Metall und andere freuen sich
natürlich darüber das wird ihre
Auftragsbücher füllen ja aber das ist
für mich jetzt schon eine andere
Situation als das was wir mögen hat
gesehen aber trotzdem ist es in einem
Punkt vergleichbar ich will ihr Beispiel
von der Rüstungsindustrie mal aufnehmen
ich glaube dass man diese Frage der
ethischen Bewertung von Gewinnen nicht
in einem Krisenjahr alleine
berücksichtigen und bewerten sollte man
muss es ja über mehrere Jahre betrachten
und nehmen das Beispiel der
Rüstungsindustrie ja weil sich die
Weltlage verändert hat was niemand
wusste werden die jetzt gebraucht und
Schreiben Gewinne aber über viele Jahre
standen die am Rand
keiner wollte die Aktien kaufen die so
unternehmen sollten auch bei der
Regulierung gebremst werden ich könnte
das weiter fortsetzen ich will damit zum
Ausdruck bringen diejenigen ja die
hatten nicht eine schwere Zeit
das ist nicht mein Argument sondern ich
will sagen im Nachhinein moralisch zu
kategorisieren in der Marktwirtschaft
fällt schwer weil es führt dazu dass das
Steuerrecht anfällig wird für politische
Werturteile für Geschmacksurteile für
stammtischurteile und da sehe ich eine
Gefahr wie war das bei den
Impfstoffherstellern da könnte man ja
auch sagen ja gut die hatten eine
Innovation und aber müssen die denn so
viele Milliarden plötzlich bekommen
müssten wir nicht dieses für die
Menschheit wichtige geistige Eigentum
sofort verstaatlichen und die Diskussion
gab es ja während der Pandemie und wurde
dazu führen dass niemand mehr ein Risiko
eingeht denn zu einem Risiko eine
Investition einzugehen von der ich nicht
weiß ob sie sich rentiert auch die
Raffinerien sind ein Risiko eingegangen
alle sagen wir machen Elektroantriebe
wir wollen kein Öl mehr jetzt sagen nee
wir investieren aber noch in die
Raffinerie und plötzlich wird sie
gebraucht also da fällt es schwer zu
sagen folge ich dem Bauch und dem Herzen
die Gewinne müssen weggesteuert werden
oder sage ich mit dem Kopf welcher
Auswirkungen hat das langfristig auch
für die Berechenbarkeit eines
Unparteiischen Steuerrechts nicht so
einfach
republikum das macht schon alles so sein
man muss eben dann eine andere
Finanzierung finden und hat dann so
gesehen die Wahl über Gewinnsteuer oder
Schulden und Schulden haben sie ja
vorhin auch gesagt ist auch nicht
unbedingt das Mittel was sie gerne
wählen und muss also ein Tod da
wahrscheinlich sterben und ich glaube
jetzt bei
übergewinnsteuer hätte man dort
stringenter gehandelt wäre natürlich
auch direkt beim Doppelpunkt weniger
also ich